d'emblée le procureur général annonce
qu'il va rendre publique la nature du
mandat de perquisition josmar
département vient tout juste de déposer
une requête dit i want you want
pour rendre public le mandat ainsi que
l'inventaire de la perquisition selon
lui il à faire est d'intérêt public à
cause de notre chambre de foire à wallis
christophe barneaud
france existe
dans notre chambre est inquiet parce
qu'ici ce qu'il ya dans les bois dit son
ancien avocat il se sent seul et piéger
c'est lundi matin vers 9 heures que des
agents du fbi se sont rendus à la
résidence de l'ex président avec un
mandat de perquisition
il aurait récupéré une douzaine de
boîtes avec des documents classés secret
censé aller aux archives nationales
depuis le camp de chambre parle d'abus
de pouvoir de persécution politique
en plus du juge fédéral qui a signé le
mandat de perquisition et ce prime le
fbi a été la cible d'attaqués sur les
réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui un homme armé a même tenté
de pénétrer dans les bureaux du fbi à
cincinnati en ohio après un état de
siège de plusieurs heures l'homme a été
abattu
je ne vais pas garder le silence dit il
alors qu'on attaque l'intégrité de nos
agents qui sont des patriotes en dévoués
qui protège la sécurité des américains
ici les spéculations vont bon train des
médias rapportent que ce serait un
proche de donald trump qui aurait alerté
le ministère de la justice et le fbi
haye que l'ancien président détenait
toujours des dossiers qui pourraient
porter atteinte à la sécurité nationale
rick ross
ce serait une personne ce proche du
président d'iti ac dans nos eaux de
pluie pour anderson personne qui ait vu
les documents de prêt et qui sait où il
se trouve
le washington post vient de révéler que
les agents du fbi est recherché des
documents portant sur l'armé nucléaire
la cour a jusqu'à 15 heures demain pour
rendre public le mandat de perquisition
et de notre homme pourrait s'y opposer
si elle est modelée guerguisse
radio-canada washington